then the night's still in trouble and
black could easily lose
he's bluffing here Nakamura Bishop takes
up and you run oh and you take it
away
but if he takes it that each one is the
wrong Corner color so white still has to
demonstrate some technique here Queen's
going to come off this is going to be an
end game it's winning for white but you
have to be a bit careful he got was so
angry at himself right now he does run
with the King
he's got 13 seconds on the clock
it will block but it's it's still some
technique to show a lot of technique to
show yep he knows he's losing but still
white needs to prove it
and the white Bishop
the legs
out of the chest kicked off yeah I like
to look at him this it's funny